and then your ball handling has to be on
point you've got to find a way to get
into the paint
so you can free people up that's a tough
shot to take though tj warren made it
though that was the shot he was going to
have to take did he get it still tj
mcconnell took the ball from milton
that's the second time and now warren
for three in a big
time first quarter for t.j warren he's
got
19. he's a scorer and they put him back
in a more natural position
to keep ben simmons on the floor and he
has it going
24 for tj warren baser's back up by
six oh now that's a heat check that is a
heat check
he caught that three steps behind the
three-point line and just
drilled it really good i mean that's a
heat check
he gets that shot to go shoot it
a step back three by warren and the
pacers have tied it at 69. that's
because of a good effort on the glass
down on the other end
when trailing after three quarters there
you go
yeah he's in rhythm ben simmons went
down
after he made his leg he's just playing
against the guy that's it's pretty good
now
oh look at tj knock it down
and you're seeing more of it warren for
three
finnish spot give him a 50 spot right
there ladies and gentlemen
that's why the [ __ ] was up and comes
down court get him the ball
you get that nobody's guarding him
holiday shot clock down to six finds
warren here's a long three
oh yeah six tenths to play
sometimes you just have it you let